[Musique]
laissez moi vous parler d'un smartphone
aujourd'hui j'ai pu le voir lors de ses
voeux ce à quelques jours à des gars en
même temps celui à 71 en même temps que
le galaxy note bis light le dise like to
be couple ait sinon c'est le même
smartphone
j'essaie de petites bêtes là que j'ai vu
l'autre jour le galaxy à 51
alors le galaxy à 51 il fait de jolies
promesses il vient succéder aux galaxies
à 50 que je vais présenter dernière il
est lumineux les couleurs sont belles il
est pratique il est sympa c'est vraiment
un très beau travail fait de la part de
synthos lan ariège pas si vous souvenez
ça me saoule à présenter plein de
modèles dans le milieu de gamme a
révolutionné son milieu montre ils
gagnent à supprimer la gabegie qui était
jusque-là l'entrée de gamme à tout
ouvert sur la gamma qui a regroupé
l'entrée de gamme et le milieu bien et
un petit peu changer la dénomination
galaxie à 20 e samsung galaxy à 40
rédaction s'inquiète samsung galaxy à 70
mail axial 80 galaxie à 90,5 j'étais là
on continue à 51 j'imagine que toute la
gamme parce que nouvelle en 2020 on a eu
lieu à 51 elle a donc je vous parle
aujourd'hui et l'a71 que j'ai vu
rapidement un écran infiniti haut avec
la petite roue directement aux votre
smartphone qui ne saurait tarder à
arriver donc vous parlerai dans quelques
jours dans une invite tout de suite dès
maintenant à vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà fait vous abonner cliquez sur
le petit bouton rouge brun se sait
jamais quel quotidien
je dirais aller en dessous je sais
jamais j'ai toujours un peu à l'envers
express de moniteurs vous cliquez en bas
ça petit bouton rouge vous actionnez la
cloche comme ça vous serez tous vous
serez avertis des prochaines vidéos y
compris des vidéos bien sûr qu'il parle
de samsung de tous les tests produits
dont on parle aujourd'hui du samsung
galaxy à 51 modèles qui est intéressant
qui fait plein de jolies promesses qui
est un format très cool regarder je peux
complètement vides affirme tour avec mes
doigts et ça ça donne plus en plus rares
au niveau des smartphones
on a quatre capteurs photos regarder la
partie arrière on a des jolis reflets ce
smartphone fait plein de jolies
promesses tout ça à 379 euros est ce
qu'au final ce samsung galaxy à 51 et le
smartphone qu'il vous faut dans milieu
de gamme oui ou non tout ça je vous en
parle ou non tout a commencé par le
design première chose qui m'a frappé que
ce smartphone ce que je trouve l'on est
relativement fin ça c'est bien pour la
prise en regard de ce pôle tenir très
facilement main je fais tour avec mes
doigts ce qui fait vraiment ça semble
avoir une bonne maîtrise sur son
smartphone alors attention bien
évidemment on est sur un smartphone qui
est un peu glissant comme hbo
smartphone et c'est pas du tout anormal
d'eau en plastique on a un écran qui
écoule à l'abandon pendant quelques
instants
vous avez un dock des reflets sais pas
si ça se vend bien il ya beaucoup
d'éclairage et si il ya un côté un petit
parc en ciel sympas ils ont vraiment
travaillé ça me saoule sur le souci du
détail là vous avez des bandes
verticales avec le branding samsung
branding dur à articuler les plannings
samsung petit différenciation vous allez
avoir ici au niveau d'une petite barre a
aussi qui part juste là que tu es un peu
plus mate un côté un peu plus brillant
et un côté un peu plus d'arc en ciel
enfin il ya eu un beau boulot et en plus
ce qui est bien c'est je trouve que le
module photo est bien intégré vous avez
donc quatre capteurs photo ça je vous en
parle dans quelques instants qui forment
un elle dans un rectangle avec le flash
est sur le côté je trouve ça plutôt bien
bien intégrés à ces jolies époque où ça
s'est vraiment bien fait de la part de
samsung tous les boutons se trouve ici
de ce côté avec bouton pour l'allumer et
les boutons de volume je tente un petit
peu à venir les confondre je viens
monter de volume sur le bouton pour
l'allumer et fall inverse bon c'est pas
grave
enfin vous avez capté le coup vous
habituer ça marche pour trouver sur le
dessous votre eau parleur mono
fonctionne aussi parfaitement bien ici
de l'usbc pour la recharge la prise jack
était conservée ça c'est vachement bien
le petit micro de ce côté là d'ailleurs
autre tiroir de cartes sim deux cartes
nanosims plus une carte micro sd pour
rire augmenté je vous en reparle dans
quelques instants le micro pour la
réduction bruit vont trouver un petit
point sont au niveau de la face avant
pour lui d'avoir une encoche bon ça
fonctionne dans le milieu de gamme ça me
dérange pas trop cyril j'ai hâte j'ai
vraiment très très hâte ça va venir ça
va pas tarder à arriver peut-être pas
tout de suite peut-être l'année
prochaine on verra ça d'ici quelques
jours hier parce que je serai présent au
lancement des prochains galaxy s 20 à
san francisco le 8 une fois de plus à
vous abonner comme ça que vous serez
tous et vous verrez tout directement
quand je serai sur place donc le petit
poisson sur un produit comme ça ça me
dérange pas on a une bordure qui a si
fine en bas soit coté aussi ses freins
c'est bien c'est joli ça j'aime bien
l'écran est tout plat je vous parle de
l'écran une fois de plus dans quelques
instants le format et l'ont vraiment
cool pour le visionnage de vidéos il
existe en 3 couleurs là j'ai la version
noire ils existent en bleu et en blanc
sauf que d'un point de vue purement
esthétique samsung a vraiment fait un
bon boulot sur ce smartphone qu'en est
il justement au niveau de cet écran ça
c'est un des points très très fort et
très bien maîtrisée de la part de
samsung les dalles de samsung sont
toujours très très bien calibrée
ici vous avez un écran infiniti infiniti
haut avec le petit trou au milieu de 6,5
pouces de diagonale écran super amoled
technologie extrêmement bien m
et de samsung résolution full hd plus de
1400 par 1080 une fois de plus samsung
vraiment très très très très très bien
travaillé au niveau de sa dalle regardez
en faire un petit tour du côté des
paramètres vous arrivez ici alors il ya
un truc à savoir c'est parce que vous
allez dans votre affichage vous avez
plusieurs possibilités
moi je me suis mis en mode vif par
défaut vous êtes en mode naturel
il est un peu moins punchy que le mode
vif mais ça fonctionne le mode dit quant
à lui vous donne des rendus beaucoup
plus percutant regardez vous le voyez
directement là je switche de l'un à
l'autre il ya la colorimétrie sur la
vidéo mais en fait ça fait ressortir les
couleurs pour sylvie son nom l'indiqué
moi ce que je vous conseille quand même
si vous devez sur le mode de vie c'est
de me réchauffer parce que par défaut
vous êtes au milieu joue un peu plus
froid vous êtes toujours bien devenir le
réchauffé je vous conseille aussi de
venir ici dans le filtre de lumière
bleue ça veut dire je n'y ai un petit
peu mais franchement c'est mieux pour la
fatigue oculaire il je vous conseille
réellement vous pouvez aussi aller sur
le mode sombres souvenirs économiser de
l'énergie pourquoi parce que tout ce que
vous allez avoir en noir sur un écran
super amoled vu que celle de l'aide tout
ce qui est noir d'un pixel noir d'un
pixel est un donc vous économisez de
l'énergie
et puis en plus ça fait moins mal aux
yeux c'est plutôt bien bon après y'a pas
mal de paramètres parce que vous tournez
sur one eye donc sûrement lieu il ya
toujours beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
paramètres je vous laisserai visiter
faire un tour ça fonctionne parfaitement
bien c'est vraiment cool très complet
c'est vraiment une super surcouche tout
ça sur un android disent ça marche c'est
vraiment cool est vraiment beaucoup de
choses à voir en termes de
confidentialité de sécurité de lait bio
métrique votre compte google vos
paramètres enfin c'est vraiment bien
soi-même plutôt rassurant pour les
parents au niveau du bien-être numérique
et les contrôles parentaux
donc ça s'est très très bien pour le
côté purement audio clement multimédia
ça fait honte à vous avez un écran qui
est très très très allongée raid et si
vous poussez la luminosité à fond pour
qu'on puisse vraiment s'en rendre compte
on a un écran qui est vraiment très très
allongée ça fait le taff ça c'est plutôt
agréable en fait ce format d'écran
larissa bien un petit peu krupp et même
beaucoup trop pris dans votre vidéo
néanmoins lorsque volet des vidéos au
format 18 9e 22e et pourquoi pas 21/9
c'est vraiment très très confortable je
regrette toujours ce petit truc son côté
mais qui est moins quand même dérangeant
qu une encoche par contre du point de
vue audio
c'est assez médiocre il ya beaucoup de
sens vraiment vraiment de toute façon il
ya un seul haut-parleur se console aussi
ce côté là partout sa qualité audio
vraiment très médiocre c'était même
rendre à toulouse
rassurez vous on a quelque chose qui est
quand même pas mal pour venir contre un
petit peu ce problème là alors vous
n'allez pas changé de haut parleurs vous
allez pas changer la qualité c'est pas
possible par contre si vous êtes
audiophiles et si vous voulez profiter
d'une meilleure expérience audio bras
relativement augmentée vous avez votre
petit choc là vous voulez mort de tout à
l'heure vous venez brancher un casque
filaire ça marche beaucoup mieux la
qualité est meilleure alors on va pas
révolutionner l'histoire on garde
toujours un son qui avec des bases un
peu médium on va venir augmenter le
spectre on va se faire un peu moins mal
aux oreilles ça c'est bien et après si
vous avez aussi un casque sans fil vous
pouvez le brancher parce que vous avez
du bluetooth 5.0 là dessus donc on a pas
mal de possibilités pour venir écouter
par contre fait attention que ce n'est
pas le volume trop fort pour éviter de
vous abîmer les oreilles et en tout cas
il ya ce qu'il faut derrière en termes
de volume sonore
et qu'en est-il au niveau des
performances parce qu'avoir un
smartphone qui est joli un smartphone
qui a un bel écran un smartphone qui est
cool pour le muc qui m'agace c'est bien
mais c'est derrière le smartphone ils
pédalent passer un petit peu compliqué
tu es ce que vaut ce smartphone galaxy à
51 en termes de performances
eh bien il est plutôt pas mal je vous ai
fait un petit test durant tout en un
score de 173 milles j'ai appris par
coeur 196 regarder celle là c'est mignon
c'est beau alors en fait qu'est ce que
ça raconte tout ça et bien ça nous
positionne dans ce qu'il est réellement
on est sur un smartphone milieu de gamme
il a donc des performances milieu de
gamme force que ça ne surprendra pas
c'est pas la machine la plus performante
c'est pas la machine la plus dingue on
trouve quelques petits ralentissements
lorsque vous allez dans les différents
modes vous allez changer d'une partie à
l'autre il ya quelques ralentissements
il va pas dans le capteur d'empreintes
digitales
le plus rapide on n'a pas non plus le
meilleur processeur derrière on tourne
sur un exynos 9611 tout cela couplé à 4
gigas de ram et au stockage vous avez
128 giga du stockage extensible grâce à
une carte microsd jusqu'à 512 igad on
l'est donc sur un smartphone qui est
réellement d'autres l'adn bien
positionné milieu de gamme
vous n'allez pas faire tourner un fork
nay de fugue dépôt à faire tourner des
jeux même un peu vieillissant problème
on va baisser en termes de performances
des jeux mais par contre tout plein de
jeux vous allez avoir ce qu'il faut pour
l'ouverture et fermeture 12 applications
ça va ça fonctionne c'est pas une
machine qui rame c'est pas non plus la
machine la plus performante mais je
dirais que pour l'usagé au quotidien vu
son tarif ça fait tâche le tonneau mais
aussi au rendez vous avec une grosse
prix de 4000 milliampères heures c'est
un smartphone qui tient la route en
fonction bien évidemment des usages et
toujours la question des usages qui
compte parce que si vous l'utilisez
façon très intensive ya un moment vous
serez sur une journée mais si par contre
vous l'utilisez j'irais peut plus
standard une journée demi à deux jours
ça fonctionne sans aucun problème vous
avez de la recharge en usb c'est c'est
assez rapide second saut quantique bon
de ce point de vue là en terme
d'autonomie vous serez pas déçus
maintenant il ya un point qui est aussi
extrêmement important la tue c'est toute
la partie photo alors je vous fais dans
les petits détails vous allez voir en
hausse et d'un capteur de 5 mégapixels
qui a pour le mode portrait qui ouvre à
f 2.2 qui va être là effectivement pour
le flou d'arrière-plan l'autre vous
allez faire des photos en mode portrait
en dessous vous avec capteur principal
5,48 mégapixels c'est un grand-angle de
80° qui ouvre à f 2.0 qui va être là
pour toutes vos photos photo standard et
pour toutes vos photos nuit vous allez
voir les photos nuit à lui mais y'a pas
que lui qui travaille en dessous vous
avez un ultra grand-angle de 123 degrés
qui ouvre à f 2.2 et là vous avez une
petite caméra 5 mégapixels également qui
est pour le mode macro parce que oui
pour faire des photos en mode macro
entre 3 à 5 cm est quant à elle elle
ouvre à f 2.4 à l'avant ici vous avez
une petite caméra de 30 2 mégapixels et
oui rien que ça que bref 2.2 à savoir
que vous avez un autofocus arrière c'est
plutôt bien y'a pas d'autofocus avant
vous pouvez filmer jusqu en 4k à 30
images par seconde vous avez de la
stabilisation en vidéo ici c'est une
stabilisation numérique il n'y a pas de
stabilisation optique je vais rentrer là
dedans je vous montrer comment ça marche
d'un point de vue logiciel après je vous
montre le résultat en termes de photos
et de vidéos et vous allez voir il ya
des choses intéressantes surprenante il
y a du bon et il ya aussi du moins ça
c'est normand la façon dont a été conçue
l'appareil photo ici dans votre
smartphone alors regardez je vous montre
quand vous arrivez vous arrivez ici dans
la partie photo
bon rien de bien complètement d'un livre
on connaît un petit peu modules
standards là vous passez sur l' ultra
grand-angle alors n'y a aucune
stabilisation aussi moi c'est vraiment
le premier truc que je vais me reprocher
une fois de plus j'ai conscience que sur
un smartphone à 379 euros qui sont au
milieu de gamme ne peut pas tout avoir
sur moi en tout cas ça pardonne pas il
me faut absolument une stabilisation et
il n'y en a pas que vous soyez sur
l'ultra grand temps que vous soyez sur
l'adjectif normal ensuite vous avez
votre mode portrait qui est ici rien de
bien déconnant vous connaissez vous les
loyers plan ça marche
la partie
ou qui est intéressante parce que vous
pouvez filmer avec la caméra principale
mais également avec votre ultra
grand-angle et ce qui est marrant vous
pouvez venir ici stabiliser vous voyez
s'il ya une petite main et vous appuyez
là vous allez avoir une stabilisation
numérique alors ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que ça bien croquer
dans l'image que vous en douterez parce
que ça vienne qui peut recadrer et ça
vient compenser le mouvement lorsque tu
sur leur caméra principale gardée hop ça
vient me up l'élargir un petit peu en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que je passe
directement sur le module
ultra-grand-angle ça vient un petit peu
rétréci bon ça fait le tard il faut
quand même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de lumière ensuite
vous avez les petits modules ici
supplémentaires module plus vous allez
pouvoir retrouver bon mode pro panorama
je vous passe la macro pour venir chuté
directement entre 3 à 5 cm je montre
résultats dans quelques instants
vous avez également le mode de nuit qui
est planqué juste là le menu prévenir
chuté directement soit avec votre
capteur principal de 48 mégapixels c'est
là très clairement d'obtenir les
meilleurs résultats
mais vous pouvez également venir chuté
avec votre ultra-grand-angle pourquoi
pas en mode nuit s'est relativement mal
an alors on ne fait plus la même nuit
allait bien oui et non parce qu'il n'ya
pas de stabilisation optique voilà
quelques photos que j'ai prises
directement avec mon samsung galaxy à 51
leurs photos nuit je le tenais à la main
vous le voyez c'est un petit peu fou
c'est là tout le problème de la
stabilisation qu'on ne retrouve pas
directement sur cet appareil pas de
stabilisation optique là par contre il
est posé et là tout de suite ça va
beaucoup mieux effectivement on a des
flous de bougé sur les personnes mais
surtout le reste il ya du détail c'est
bien une fois de plus la photo de nu
c'est plutôt bien ça restitue pas trop
mal on passe sur l' ultra grand-angle je
trouve ça un petit peu moins précis on
continue photo nuit ultra-grand-angle ça
bave un peu plus au niveau des lumières
la gestion est quand même relativement
moins bonne la série photos que j'ai
prises lors d'une balade familiale et je
trouve que c'est pas mal mais sa
tendance un petit peu et lycées on voit
un peu le détail directement au niveau
du lac on le voit un petit peu dans le
ciel c'est un peu surprenant je prends
des photos avec l'ultra grand temps
qu'on dit regardez on est une vraie
différence de colorimétrie vous vous en
rendrez compte sur les photos un peu
plus lourd
la macro tout ça a quand même
relativement rigaux c'est dommage puisse
pas se rapprocher davantage 3,5 cm c'est
bien ça ne paraît pas réellement de
l'anacr au taux des photos plutôt
proches mais pas réellement de la macro
capteur principal ultra-grand-angle à
vous voyez vraiment la différence du
colorimétrie toutes les parties vers son
plus saturées sur le très grand-angle
que sur le capteur principal toutes les
parties marron sont
beaucoup plus saturés beaucoup plus
prononcée ça peut paraître un peu moins
précis avec ultra grand-angle mais ça va
c'est pas déconner on se retrouve avec
le mode portrait alors le mode portrait
je trouve qu'il s'est quand même pas
trop mal le taf il a un peu de mal
lorsque je viens de raccrocher entre les
doigts on n'est pas sur un smartphone
complètement dingue la qualité est pas
complètement pas non plus on est sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme capteur
principal ultra-grand-angle sent moins
précis un luth racontant une façon un
peu général est outre au niveau du ciel
ça a tendance un petit peu alice et même
au niveau de l'eau voyez le ciel la
salisse au niveau de l'os alice ça ne
paraît pas complètement fou fou à côté
de ça ça bouge et demont s'est pas non
plus complètement déconnant photos
prises dans une barque on passe sur
l'ultra grand-angle grosse différence de
colorimétrie plage essaie de faire
quelques fautes au niveau de la macro au
niveau de petites bulles dans l'eau à la
bouche ce n'est pas toujours évident
s'en rendre compte mais néanmoins le taf
et fait donc ça va c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal
on passe devant la caméra de celle-ci
nous a parlé d'une belle tête de
pingouins ou je sais pas quoi là dessus
ça fait le boulot 30 2 mégapixels
ça marche et là des convient ou mais dès
qu'on va chercher avec le zoom on va
jusqu'à un zoom numérique au but eh bien
je trouve ça pas terry de la fed sur une
fois deux fois deux et demi je viens le
chercher davantage contre x 8 regardez
c'est ultra lisse et c'est pas beau on
devine absolument rien je vous
déconseille de venir zoomer avec ce
smartphone c'est pas fait pour ça dans
tous les cas tout ce que j'ai essayé le
rendu est vraiment pas du tout
qualitatif caméra principale juliet zhu
mais ils sont jusqu aux os x 8 voyez
c'est très imprécis c'est pas très très
haut la macro c'est marrant pour une
petite distance 3 5 cm c'est pas le tout
le plus fou le plus révolutionnaire on
arrive quand même à ajouter quelques
petites choses à la secte au milieu on
voit bien les détails sur la souche de
l'arbre caméra principale
ultra-grand-angle là on vient le
chercher il voyait une fois de plus avec
le zoom c'est très imprécis la partie
vidéo c'est partout que plus d'un nom
plus sur ce smartphone pour filmer ou 4k
30 images par seconde pour faire le
choix de venir activer la stabilisation
le rendu est pas fou le rendu fonctionne
mais c'est pas un smartphone qui est
fait pour faire de la vidéo mais vous
attendez pas à voir les meilleurs
résultats soit pour partager de la story
sur instagram que ce soit pour faire de
la création pure et dure du montage
arrière pour faire un buzz vidéo
souvenir mais vous n'allez pas aller
bien loin avec bien évidemment on a du
nfc on a du wifi 5 dessus smartphones
que moi je trouve bien dans l'absolu je
trouve intéressant alors ce smartphone
il pas fait pour tout le monde il est
pas fait pour les personnes qui veulent
vivre quelque chose de très exigeant en
termes de photos qui veulent aller très
loin qui veulent une superbe qualité
mais par contre si vous voulez profiter
d'un bon écran de bonne qualité bien
calibré là dessus vous serez absolument
pas déçu pour le contenu multimédia
c'est vraiment pas mal
une fois de plus ça peut pêcher un petit
du côté de l'audio parce que c'est assez
médiocre mais c'est pas extrêmement
grave ça dépend bien évidemment ce que
vous voulez en faire pour regarder des
films et séries vous mettez un petit
casque filaire ou bluetooth ça
fonctionnera merveilleusement même
l'aspect multimédia pour moi il est
maîtrisé là dessus vous n'allez pas très
très très loin parce que vous n'êtes pas
suffisamment de performance mais je
dirais que pour venir jouer à pas mal de
jeux du plastoc vous pouvez faire donc
multimédia visionnage jeu on est ok
partie photo on est bien lorsque vous
aurez beaucoup de lumière en faible
luminosité va falloir venir stabiliser
c'est pas un smartphone complètement fou
on est à 379 euros et vul tarifs vu le
positionnement et vu ce que vous avez en
face à la concurrence je pense que
samsung est très bien placé là dessus en
plus ils sont positionnés avec quatre
capteurs peut-être que trois capteurs
aurait fait peut-être le capteur macro
et un petit peu lent trop bon c'est un
peu la course au kafteur hautement et
puis je me passe aussi du côté de la
marque il faut être également présents
sont tous ce segment là et venir
vraiment draguer les utilisateurs avec
de plus en plus de capteurs où va
s'arrêter la course aux capteurs on ne
sait pas encore on en parlera plus tard
on regardera ça d'ailleurs plus en plus
de capteurs et justement notamment sur
les samsung galaxy s 20 qui sera
probablement la dénomination duo de
galles sam souvent 2020 dr savard pour
ça j'ai dit dès maintenant à vous
abonner à actionner la cloche à
l'activité comme ça vous serez un tour
parce que comme je vous le disais je
serai d'ici quelques jours à san
francisco avec samsung pour aller
découvrir la nouvelle gamme et même les
nouveaux smartphones pliable de la
marque y croyez moi ça m'a vraiment pas
selon super intéressant sur ce je vous
embrasse m'établir tout ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaires si vous
intéresse je vous ai mis les liens les
jeter un petit coup d'oeil on se fait
des baies qu on s'envole de l'amour on
s'envoie du loch et puis à demain ni des
bisous [ __ ]
[Musique]